come on
password if you wear a mask and you have
an iphone with face id
you know this standoff very well except
that might change for you soon
a new update to the iphone ios 14.5
is going to have a special face id
unlock trick
you just need one of these yep if you're
wearing an apple watch your iphone can
unlock without seeing your full
face how does it work if your watch is
unlocked on your wrist and your iphone
is nearby but can't read your full face
your watch will buzz and face id will
unlock
and you're in it's pretty awesome here's
what's happening behind the scenes
face id tries to identify you as usual
if it can't see your nose and mouth
it looks for your unlocked watch to
confirm it's you
there's no actual scanning of your eyes
or what's still visible of your face
see even with my eyes closed it lets me
in
how well does it work pretty darn well
other than the fact that you need to
have an apple watch which starts at 200
talk about being masked in by apple
let's do some speed tests mask free face
id
0.8 seconds face id with a mask
and the watch feature enabled 1.4
seconds
and a fingerprint sensor on the iphone
se 0.7 seconds
getting in with a six-digit passcode a
year
okay fine three seconds worried about
security and someone getting into your
phone if they have your watch
yeah it can be done but it's not likely
each time you put on your watch you turn
on this whole auto unlock feature
on your iphone by entering your iphone
passcode
if someone has that they won't need your
watch anyway
a bigger fear is someone like masked man
kenny here
grabbing your phone and unlocking it
just by being close to the unlocked
watch on your wrist
what are you gonna do with my phone
tweets access to her venmo
suite but apple has some protection
against this
you can tap here to quickly lock the
phone from your wrist
in my tests the iphone and the watch
have to be within 10 feet of each other
this is beta software so this and other
things may change
plus this apple watch shortcut is only
good for unlocking your iphone
if you're wearing a mask while trying to
buy something using apple pay the app
store or itunes
the phone will still require your
password
so how do you get it your iphone needs
to be running ios 14.5
and your apple watch needs to be running
watch os 7.4
plus you have to turn it on by going
into settings
face id and passcode and turning on
unlock
with apple watch right now those
operating systems are in beta
and if you don't want to wait until the
final release this spring
you can sign up for apple's beta program
now anyone can do this but it's
unfinished software so
there can be bugs or battery drain so
far
so good for me but download at your own
risk
either way this software update cannot
come soon enough
you